welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen
I am Priyanka Vergara and in this
episode we will talk about creating
static websites on Google cloud let's
say you're a small company looking to
set up a basic web presence you don't
expect a lot of traffic and don't want
to pay a lot to get up and online so
let's walk through how to start small
deploying a static website static web
pages can contain client-side
technologies such as HTML CSS and
JavaScript they cannot contain dynamic
content such as server-side scripts like
PHP before you begin make sure that you
have a google cloud project created a
billing account set up and you have a
domain that you own or manage this
should be your top-level domain to
verify that you manage the domain check
the link in the description below now
that you've covered the logistics there
are four steps to setup static websites
the first step is to connect your domain
to Google Cloud storage to do that
create a cname record that points to
CDOT storage Google API is calm the
second step is to create a Google Cloud
storage bucket to do this
browse to the Google Cloud console click
on cloud storage and click create bucket
make sure the bucket name matches the
cname you created for your domain in
this case the storage bucket should be
named www.example.com
the third step is to upload the files
you want your website to serve you can
do this in one of two ways first by
directly uploading the files using the
Google cloud console or second by using
gsutil command line which is great for
when you have an existing website once
the files are uploaded accessing them is
going to be based on how you choose to
share your files if you set the
permission at the bucket level you can
easily and quickly make every file for
your site publicly
for finer control you can choose to set
the permission at the object level so
that only specific files are accessible
through your website at this point you
have a functioning static website and
you could call it a day but we recommend
assigning an index page suffix and a
custom error page to better guide your
users this helps in situations when a
user might request your URL but you do
not have an Associated file with that
name in your bucket in our example when
there isn't a file named Apple cloud
storage will attempt to serve an indexed
our HTML if that file also doesn't exist
cloud storage will return an error page
with the 404 response now the fourth and
final step is to test our static web
site verify that the content is served
from the bucket by requesting the domain
name in a browser one important thing to
note here is that Google Cloud Storage
only supports HTTP in order to serve
HTTPS and get all the security goodness
you need to either use direct your eyes
using a cname redirect or migrate to
using a load balancer as a front-end so
today we learned how to start small and
deploy a static website on Google cloud
platform we used Google Cloud Storage to
host the static content and pointed the
domain name to the storage bucket that's
all for today on get cooking in cloud
here's hoping you can whip up something
great join us next time because we will
share the recipe to host websites on
manage platform cloud run if you like
this video then check out our first
episode as well and to see more such
content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]